il était sur la scène du théâtre de
champ fleuri en début d'année et les
revoilà en cette fin d'année les jeunes
danseurs des new gravity virevolte
sautent dansent et s'accroche aux murs
du théâtre de champ fleuri du parvis de
champ fleuri à la scène en passant
désormais par l'expo les petits danseurs
sont devenus grands commencé très bas
très très bon centre de tout ça dans la
rue sur des places pour arriver là mais
pas
il est tellement phoque voilà les
tablettes annonce plaisir que je suis
parmi vous ce soir pour lancer la
nouvelle saison des théâtres
départementaux
côté danse justement de pointures devenu
depuis peu directeur de l'opéra de paris
benjamin millepied présent son aile et
dance projet
et il y aura d'autres danseurs venus de
madagascar ou encore de 9 à découvrir
également kaffrine de medjani dance
company ont l'exploration d'une identité
noire réunionnaise dans un décor plongée
dans l'obscurité
et puis on trouve la musique
réunionnaise et le meilleur sera pour la
fin puisque firmin viry fête ses 80 ans
le 12 décembre à 20h j'ai filmé le grand
chantre du maloya
pour guy gels amitiés particulières qui
vient d'arrêter cette accréditation
athènes les agiles quand la bourriche
travail et vie télé jean gallice les
paroles apprend qu'on changera par
l'état s'ils lui l'esprit de la gagne et
l'inscrit à nos cuisines et les salles
gérées iphone huchet respecter hills 4
mondial dû à leur vie si la théâtre à
manger les revues à me convaincre et
charmant plusieurs artistes seront sur
la scène du théâtre plein air de
saint-gilles un théâtre en plein air qui
accueillera une soirée hommage à alain
peters
on retrouve des dalons l'ale ehrlich
bernard brancard l'infini peters
international et ou encore daniel waro
il est
et
j'ai pilé
il l est
il gèle tout et je vais aimer autant
octobre qui est un groupe émergent
tricot de peau qui est un groupe
émergent nicolas givran qui fait du
théâtre émergents que firmin viry cad
d'être cas dominique barret kakal obadia
il peut pas choisir pas là c'est ça ce
qui plaît à nous aussi et comme l'arrêt
comme la réunion on est un peuple
multiples je reviens cette histoire de
cuisine parce que je suis un gourmand et
voilà je suis un épicurien
on n'a pas à choisir entre la cuisine et
chinois la cuisine mal bas qu'ici la
raba cuisine créole amende au nez si on
a envie de manger quelque chose dont on
le déguste
ben voila moi je veux que c'était at on
continue à déguster quand on en a envie
ce que l'on a envie et qu'on est le plus
large choix possible et voilà c'est
simplement à l'image de cette équipe au
programme également le bal réunionnais
de l'afrique enchantée avec bilal des
solos la nièce hortense les mercenaires
de l'ambiance bernard joron nathalie
natiembe danyel waro ira gérer les 9 et
10 octobre le théâtre plein air vous
propose donc de partir sur les traces du
séga du maloya des traditions mais c'est
bien un pouvoir métissé qui se poursuit
avec la découverte de kalou badia
cabarry de benjam ou encore le maloya
surprenant d'octobre deux jeunes femmes
une voix un rouleur et la magie opère
et puis davy sicard nous donne rendez
vous pour découvrir son nouvel album
aux enfants donc le dernier album que
les sorties la fin mai et puis va
surtout en fait le but pour moi
le 5 décembre ce sera deux invitent
plusieurs gènes
plusieurs élèves en fait y apprendre la
musique est associé à zatta ce
concert-là festival du court pas john
dominique barret anaïk morel et diamal
mokaddem en récital voilà une belle
manière pour bien terminer l'année
rendez vous sur le site des théâtres
pour la programmation complète
pensez y